this is the opening special oh [__] it's
that time [__] will back yeah
subscribe on your ass [__] I hope
you're ready to [__] rock tonight
[Music]
jeez up hoes down you bad [__]
if that [__] can't swim she's bound to
drizzle
[Music]
oh [__]
use a penguin look at [__]
oh [__] here we go [__] up is the
church coming at you on a Monday night
little attitude adjustment
first off my heart and my soul goes out
to the victims of Vegas [__] tragedy
but we're gonna get through this
oh [__] mr. Buster where the [__] you at
what oh [__] we're going deep tonight
[__] look at this don't even
respect your ass that's why it's time
for the doctor to check that [__] ass
[__] used to be my ace oh [__]
[Music]
[__] me no [__] you little on what
it's the cloud of death which uncle
[__] Joey
and his beautiful Jewish assessment rosh
hashanah li that is big G coz you lost
all your homies blood oh [__] you
thought it was gonna be a [__] take
top take diaper night but uncle Joey and
[__] the Christ killer I'm coming
into your living room [__]
alright buys you right now to get this
party started let the little boy go
yeah I'm sayin oh [__] punk
[__] here we go Bow Wow Wow ub
yo u pj uncle Joey's in the
[__] house wow wow wow yippee
yippee NATO with my phone little Jimmy
this is but tonight we're going five
deep tonight [__] your mama I'm talking
about you and me toe to toe
oh [__] you wanna do something let's see
you [__] do it [__] if you're
on day 18 hang up now you little [__]
and want unless you know that when you
[__] with Dre [__] you [__] with
death row these are delicious tonight
nutritious and gluten free for you half
the [__] California [__] out there
here we go we're gonna split this one
we're on five hundred just on the
[__] TKO just to show you how we do
it here
[Music]
cuz I used to hang with ez animosity
with my nuts on your tonsils what you
thought it was gonna be a [__] nun oh
[Music]
[__] oh [__] put your hands up brothers
it's that type of night [__]
I'm trying to tell you we're doing it
the right way here and you guys are
doing it the right way we're trying at
least everyday well a little better look
police bump it to himself already he's
having a hard time you don't know
nothing how do you bring the mushrooms
that's Wednesday night
[Music]
are you [__] kidding me people Monday
night then we drop it like this what
have you done lately [__] death
row is in the house yeah yeah oh yeah oh
oh [__]
he's eaten either fix that dig what dig
love oh yeah yeah yeah nah there's no
reason to be something don't know me to
be so where's my main man bong hit
Johnny we're gonna open up with a little
bit of this debt and then we're gonna
switch up to a different debt want to be
a [__]
[Music]
beautiful see now wanna break out the
big gun Aerosmith [__] around tonight
get any plants canceled because we're
going deep tonight it's a good night to
go deep it's a good night to be with the
boys tonight you know what today was a
bad day in America oh [__] with all the
[__] sing
[Music]
we got the [__] to kill they blink
[Laughter]
[Music]
always on top the [__] THC game only
they know so far Kolb on the churches
those [__] can suck my dick
[Music]
a slight pinkness over october and
everybody's gotta quit all for those
[__] most gotta [__] quit one guy
can't be [__] different than the
others I heard all the beats that age
see why I don't get involved you see
that that's why my my [__] business
and I suggest you do the same oh [__]
[Music]
is it drink everyday hunger this [__]
live at the booth rule out the only
thing we're looking for is you here and
all the [__] saying and that's it and
that's it
you know I'm saying I don't know you
[__] that black but I got a lot
more plan than you [__] guys at least
I'm somewhere smoking some reefer eat
some edibles on a Monday night get my
head together for the rest of the
[__] week it was a bad week in
America nobody even cares about the
Puerto Ricans don't wanna
did you watch World News Tonight not one
mention of Puerto Rico didn't even have
a salsa commercial on it's over there on
their own
now this [__] tried to be [__] Porto
Rico up bad they're forgotten soldiers
down thank God renamed cars y'all is
putting together a [__] things on my
page it's on there I my Twitter page
donate help Renee out remains a solid
dude from the Bronx old school New York
old school PR [__]
bike the whole thing comes to all the
shows and got them brings edibles he's
got a little thing for Puerto Rico he's
like like $2,000 it's been a bad month
for donations I'm saying if you're a
donator we donate our ass off this month
cancer houston blow it up for the RICO
now blood I can't give blood so you
gotta [__] argue I gave money to the
[__] cat farthing Houston that police
it was crazy so it's little donation
month man so much you gotta check some
much you write [__] checks my knees
which I want to thank for you is coming
home tomorrow so you guys that donate
the Lyndsey running I owe you
[__] she comes home tomorrow
they did the last bone marrow test today
to see if she was in remission the
results would come back but she feels
better she's going on you don't want to
thank you guys for all the support from
lead you guys the Greg Garcia from oz
everybody I love you [__]
Bob will Amy are you [__] and
that's it that's that [__]
what time 7:54 and your mother's a dirty
[__] it's that type of party and don't
forget october 12th 13th and 14th or
something like that eleven twelve i'm at
the tab for [__] in prague and the
following Thursday lexington
[__] kentucky [__] uncle
Joey's coming swinging dick and give it
our [__] southern [__] ukuleles or
whatever the [__] they got over there
where they go anyway one thing I want to
drink champagne cap champagne not them
anyway you know I love you we'll start
this [__] in a few minutes
get your life together uncle Joey loves
you to get my heart the church [__]
family you know us we're stronger than
debt we extend our hearts to the victims
of the [__] dumb Vegas massively you
know I love you [__] stay black
brother back
[Music]